what up space fam girls in here from
animeappro and I'm back at it again to
discuss the very hype topic of Luffy's
real Bounty and how he is in fact right
now the Most Wanted Man of all time this
is huge hype stuff so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy seeing
these one piece videos like this one and
want to keep them coming Trail the inner
pirate king with it and smash that like
button until you see fireworks be a
smashing pirate king rather than passing
Orochi and the universe will reward you
accordingly join the nakama by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell if you haven't already
so you don't miss future one piece
videos updates and chapters and let me
know if you want to see these kinds of
bounty videos for any other specific
characters now it's time again to thank
the one and only raid Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video fun fact there are
7.5 billion humans in the world that
could be playing raid Shadow Legends
right now so why waste time you might as
well check it out right now raid is an
awesome mobile game that just keeps
growing and now has almost 700 champions
for you to collect and fight with
including the cool new faction called
the Sylvan Watchers you like Forest
elves or scary yet cool looking tree
Spirit then you'll love the Sylvan
Watchers who made their home in the Mist
wood a huge jungle in the east of
Talaria my favorite is the Legendary
Green Warden ruark his mask and armor
are Uber cool and the faces in his chest
and shield simultaneously freak me out
and intrigue me raid has prepared
something special for all new players
this Christmas get ready to celebrate
the 12 days of raid download raid Shadow
legends from the links below copy your
player ID from in game and then go to
12daysofrade.playerium.com enter your
player ID and then set out on a festive
Adventure that lasts 12 Days running
from December 19th to January 10th each
day experience a new chapter of this
wintry story and play a new Mini-Game
for a chance to win amazing in-game and
real life prizes including holiday
themed raid Champions and even Amazon
gift cards worth up to one thousand
dollars and don't worry if you already
play since existing raid players can
also go to 12 days of raid.playerium.com
where you can find a special holiday
promo code that everyone can use for a
small festive gift but there's more new
players use my link or scan the QR code
right here and get a free starter pack
with this cool in-game Loot and now MMA
and pro wrestling Mega star Ronda Rousey
has made an exciting leap into the world
of raid with her very own Champion you
can get Rhonda by simply opening raid on
seven days before February 20th that's
all there is to it to celebrate her
arrival you can use promo code raidronda
to get a bunch of useful in-game items
to help her level up just enter the
promo code in-game and all the goodies
will be sent straight to your inbox now
let's jump to Luffy's yonko bounty
reveal at the end of wano his Bounty was
3 billion along with kids Bounty and
laws Bounty yeah believe it or not they
all got the same Bounty despite the fact
that Luffy beat kaido the living yonko
with the highest Bounty at the time
which was
4.611 billion seems kind of crazy since
law and kid teamed up to take down big
mom who had a lower Bounty of 4.388
billion so I'm completely fine with law
and kid having a lower Bounty than big
mom because it took both of them to do
it but to have Luffy having a bounty the
same as theirs after he fought and beat
kaido alone makes no sense kaido did
take initial shots from others like the
scabbards Zoro Yamato and so on but
Luffy had a prolonged and extended
one-on-one fight with him afterward
where kaido thrived for most of it and
even had enough energy to use his final
technique flame dragon torch until Luffy
finally came out on top a comment at the
time of the reveal that this was because
the Marines were purposely lowballing
Luffy's bounty at the time and the
information we got since then definitely
supports that not to mention the fact
that some truly crazy stuff has happened
since then that would further justify a
huge increase in Luffy's bounty we got
another clue that bounties don't
actually reflect the character's true
Threat Level when Buggy's new Bounty was
revealed Yanko Buggy's Bounty was even
higher than Luffy's at 3.189 billion
this makes no sense knowing what we know
but if we think of the fact that
bounties are a tool of the world
government then things start to make
more sense we know the world government
and specifically the five Elders were
upset that when Luffy's bounty poster
revealed his gear 5 form AKA has
awakened Sun God form why it was because
they wanted to avoid the world finding
out about the hero of Liberation at all
costs because if they start to believe
in Sun God Nika again and his power to
liberate others the world governments
hold over the people of the world will
be weakened the sun God's presence could
inspire revolts all over until the world
government collapsed so we already see
that they don't want to bring any extra
attention on to Luffy thus it makes
sense that they lowballed his Bounty too
if they actually gave him the highest
Bounty ever recorded then all eyes would
be on him which they want to avoid at
all costs some may say why give him a
bounty increase at all in that case but
if they didn't that would be just a
suspicious the world government rather
chose to use bounties to make it seem
like Luffy was just an equal part of a
supernova Alliance that included law and
kid and together the three took down to
yonko this way Luffy doesn't get any
special attention even though he
obviously he should because he took down
kaido the man called the strongest
creature in the world further bounties
were revealed after Luffy's bounty
reveal including mihawks even though
mihawk is not ayanko his Bounty is a
shocking 3.59 billion so very impressive
higher than two yonko bounties which
again is a sign that Luffy's is too low
so we've established that bounties
aren't always real in other words they
aren't always Fair reflections of a
pirate's power or more importantly
Threat Level to the world government
sometimes like in Luffy's case they can
use bounties as a tool to downplay a
person that could be the key to their
own downfall so with this in mind let's
continue talking about why Luffy should
undoubtedly have the highest bounty in
history and yes I mean higher than
pirate king Goldie Rogers Bounty of
5.5648 billion obviously there is a
basic power argument since Luffy beat
kaido the man hailed as the strongest
creature in the world so his new
awakened strength alone should
accelerate him above kaido's ballet 4.6
611 billion but it's not all about power
more importantly it's about a
character's Threat Level to the world
government and strength is just one
factor of this equation lineage and
connections are factors too Luffy is
already impressive but considering he's
Marine hero garp's grandson and the
world's worst criminal dragon's son it
means that he has insane genes and is
likely to only get stronger as he gets
older like his dad and Granddad did
aside from the genes in the government's
view it's not a stretch that Luffy and
the revolutionaries could join forces
not only is Dragon Luffy's father but
flame Emperor Sabo is also his brother
beyond that Luffy and the
revolutionaries clearly have overlapping
goals the revolutionaries want to
liberate the world from the world
government while Luffy is the newest
incarnation of the legendary Warrior of
Liberation sun god Nika not to mention
he's like always liberating people
wherever he goes he is the symbol that
the revolutionaries can milk more than
any other and the symbol that the world
government fears more than any other as
we learn from who's whose story about
his own experience with the story of the
sun god even an enemy like who's who
turned to the symbol of the Sun God and
subsequently had to escape prison
because anyone who speaks or knows of
the story of Nika suspiciously
disappears and he thought he would be
next so anyways beyond having to include
sun god Luffy's obvious connections to
the revolutionaries into his Threat
Level they should also include the fact
that he's garb's grandson too and if
GARP doesn't go out of his way to help
Luffy which ultimately he might they can
at least be sure they can't count on
GARP one of their strongest fighters to
take down Luffy and while we're on
connections let's just point out his
connection to Shanks too the current
Yoko with the highest Bounty this
connection is not Irrelevant in fact
shank stepped in and helped Luffy
multiple times including at marineford
and when he scared off Admiral green
bull recently they are arguably rivals
in the race to the one piece yes but one
cannot ignore the fact that Shanks has
been an ally to Luffy and attacking
Luffy could mean dealing with Shanks too
and Awakening the red hair's wrath
mihawk himself commented on how Luffy
possesses the most dangerous ability in
this entire ocean the ability to turn
those around him into allies now I won't
go into all of his other allies and
alliances but you get the idea if you
mess with Luffy you mess with a lot of
strong people another reason why his
Bounty should be higher than even Goldie
Rogers is because Goldie Roger was too
early as he found out prophecies and
Destiny are things in one piece and
Goldie Roger found out from them that he
was too early to topple the world
government and if he found this out
chances are imusama and the higher-ups
in the world government also did Luffy
however is not too early he's right on
time in the fact that he awakened the
sun god fruit after 800 years of no one
doing it and that he's the New Joy boy
make him more of a threat to the world
government than Roger ever was then
there's the obvious fact that Luffy is
the leader of a yonko crew an amazing
yonko crew and Threat Level is not just
about individual power but takes into
account that person's influence which
obviously includes their crew Luffy now
has three other characters on his crew
with bounties over 1 billion including
Zorro Jimbo and Sanji and not to mention
Robin is really close as well big mom
only had katakuri and yet her Bounty was
so much higher than Luffy's not to
mention the fact that like Luffy beat
kaido his crew members beat all of
kaido's strongest commanders clearly any
way you look at it the 3 billion Berry
Bounty was criminally low for Luffy and
made no sense except as a means for
underplaying him and not drawing any
extra attention to him but since that
reveal Luffy has continued to build his
notoriety he now appears to have joined
forces with fellow Supernova jewelry
Bonnie and more importantly with
vegapunk the best scientist in the world
and the one who created the pacifists
including the overpowered seraphims
based on the Warlords Momo's artificial
mythical Zone devil fruit and many many
more game-changing things vegapunk is
viewed as being so dangerous that the
Marines were about to end him while
protecting his technology and greatest
achievements so that they could use them
to maintain their Supremacy and make
sure that no one gets similar
technological weapons or finds out the
weaknesses to them if they do exist
luckily for us Luffy has already agreed
to take vegapunk on board he also
outclassed an awakened Luchi in a short
fight although he left before Luchi was
actually down for good so we may see a
rematch soon we know that the seraphims
in a way are seen as the Pinnacle of
vegapunk science but as long as vegapunk
is with the straw hats these ultimate
weapons are useless because vegapunk is
above the authority trip owners in the
pacifista authority hierarchy thus
there's a chance that the straw hats
could recruit the seraphims and only the
five Elders would be able to outrank
Mega punk in Authority but it's hard to
see them showing up on the battlefield
plus they're old and potentially
vulnerable so it's only a matter of time
before they may pass away too and that's
not to mention the possibility that
since he created them Mega Punk could
potentially find a way to bring down the
seraphims through a weakness or other
invention however it must be said he
will be more limited without the same
funds that the world government could
provide so as hype as it would be to
think the straw hats could create
artificial mythical fruits more and more
it's hard to believe they have enough
money yet to finance these things of
course if they find the one piece and
Luffy becomes pirate king which they are
planning to do I'm sure money wouldn't
be an issue and that's a very real
possibility that the world government no
doubt fears and we haven't even gotten
to how the government went out of their
way to try and destroy the knowledge and
history in the tree of knowledge library
at O'Hara vegapunk actually read all
those books with all those Secrets the
government wants to erase at all costs
so as he says all the world's Mysteries
that O'Hara deciphered are right in his
brain where he has carried on the great
work of researching them in other words
he knows all of O'Hara's Revelations and
discoveries and has even been taking
them further himself we've seen how bad
they wanted Robin who was at O'Hara
because of what she knows so you can
just imagine how much more they'd want
vegapunk who has all the knowledge then
of course as was recently revealed
vegapunk has a close connection to
dragon as well they actually both pretty
much wanted Freedom vegapunk's dream is
to make an energy available and free for
all which would be a nightmare for the
world government people would definitely
be harder to control in that situation
megapunk just took a different approach
from Dragon to keep your enemies closer
approach and give me more money approach
but now that his cover is blown and he's
no longer on good terms with the world
government chances are and I'd actually
go as far as to say it's almost
guaranteed that Dragon will join forces
with his old Ally not to mention his son
and help him go up against the world
government first though the straw hats
have to successfully leave Egghead with
vegapunk and that will it seems require
them taking down Admiral kizaru who is
on his way to Egghead with more military
might thus Luffy and crew will
potentially now take down not only cp0
and more Marines but at least one
Admiral that if it happens and Oda is
making it seem like it might will
further Propel Luffy's bounty ahead of
any other think about it some of the
greatest military weapons are the
seraphims and the Admirals and if Luffy
successfully takes vegapunk while
neutralizing the threat of the seraphims
in an admiral girl then he's practically
proven that the government can't do
anything to him and that would make his
Threat Level off the charts so with all
of this in mind I think it's clear how
Luffy's real Bounty could already be 10
billion or at least could be 10 billion
berries real soon one thing's for sure 3
billion is a ridiculous number and I
don't see how anyone could think that's
a fair Bounty personally but Luffy isn't
the only person to watch another person
whose Bounty is about to shoot up is
Blackbeard Luffy's greatest antagonist
and the man who is about to take on
Luffy's Grandpa GARP if you want to see
how it's only a matter of time until
Blackbeard surpasses Shanks check out my
all 16 Blackbeard pirates and their
powers explained video link on screen
right now and in the description